the Google cloud town solution job
search API uses machine learning to
determine the relevance of job listings
when a user searches for jobs let's talk
a bit more about what determines search
relevance if you haven't seen the
previous videos in this series I
definitely recommend checking them out
jobs and companies have quite a few
properties that the machine learning
models reference to determine the
relevance of search results you can
influence that relevance significantly
by providing more information or using
things like custom ranking and feature
jobs of course search result relevance
can be complex to measure especially
since different things are relevant to
different people the job search API uses
an algorithm based on a few signals from
the job data one of the most important
properties is geographic location both
companies and jobs have location
properties but the job location will be
used over the company location when a
user does a search you should be using
the specific address fields for jobs and
companies so that the API can geolocate
it and use it to return the most
relevant jobs for a search if someone
searches for San Francisco they probably
want to see jobs in and around San
Francisco first and foremost the next
determination is how fresh a job is
basically newer jobs are ranked higher
than updated our older jobs like all of
these signals it's used in combination
with the data to make sure the search
results are relevant so a newer job
that's completely unrelated shouldn't
show up at the top just because it's new
the title and description of a job play
a major role in determining if it's
right for a search query of course if a
job for a scrum master is posted and the
description mentions managing software
developers then a search for software
development manager should include that
job make sure to avoid just stuffing a
bunch of keywords into a job description
or you may end up with some less
relevant jobs being surfaced the API
also has some parameters that you can
pass when doing a search to better
control the results keyword match lets
you enable or disable if the search
should look for keywords beyond the
regular ml driven search results
broadening will widen the search scope
for the given parameters allowing you to
get more results for a search
diversification level lets you choose if
similar job should appear
near each other in search results or if
you should only display the most
relevant one
check out the earlier best practices
video to see some more details on these
there's also a lot of features of the
API to consider when searching such as
any filters of type like employment or
distance from a location using the
commute search options lets you filter
by how long it would take to travel to
and from the job using featured jobs
lets you promote individual jobs so they
could appear in their own promoted
section you can even enable custom
ranking to manually influence search
results based on your different custom
fields with all of these factors in play
the API has a lot of considerations when
determining which jobs are most relevant
to a search your business logic may also
dictate certain requirements which you
can achieve through the search
parameters and API features in addition
the ML models will tune over time if
you've hooked up the API events as users
interact with your job search so if
you're seeing results that are
unexpected or surprising when doing a
search here's a quick checklist to help
investigate what might be happening
first up if a job isn't showing up when
you think it should be make sure to
check the details with all the factors
we just mentioned it's important to
double check the title description
location and any of the filters that may
be on the search that might exclude it
also check to see that the job hasn't
expired yet since expired jobs won't
return in the results if the search
request has diversification level
enabled the job you're looking for may
have been moved to the end of the list
because a more relevant and very similar
job was displayed first on the other
hand if a job is showing up and results
in it shouldn't be you should still
start to check with the job details when
checking for details make sure to look
at the location for the job and if the
search request may include a location
since that may push this job higher up
in relevance
additionally check to see if the search
request has enabled broadening turned on
which will relax some of the stricter
job search conditions to return more
jobs if a job is showing up a lower in
the search results than you would expect
you'll definitely want to check
everything on the search request custom
ranking featured jobs keyword matching
and diversification level can all
heavily affect the order in which jobs
show up you should also look at the
location of the search and the more
relevant jobs to see if they
closely aligned also don't forget to
check the freshness of the job posting
to see if the more relevant jobs are
also more recent if the locations for a
job are showing up incorrectly or nem
expected places check the derived
location information for a job the
information provided for the job
location may have targeted the job
somewhere else than intended or the job
may be inheriting its location from the
parent company make sure using the
addresses filled with a full address
rather than putting the address in the
description or putting something not
specific enough like just California if
a job isn't returning for some searches
that use industry specific terms it's
most likely that those terms aren't
recognized by the job search API if
you've hooked up events handling the ML
models will train themselves over time
to better match searches for those words
in addition you can use custom fields to
include synonyms and other search values
to help more jobs show up when an
industry term is used these are some
steps you can check as you integrate and
debug the implementation of the API if
you're still not sure what's going on
make sure to grab the request ID from
your search request which is returned
with every API request that ID has all
the information for the search and you
can provide it to the support team so
that they can help figure out what's
going on if you file a support request
as you can see there's a lot of power in
the job search API if you haven't
already check out our previous videos
and the documentation for a deeper dive
on these subjects thanks for watching
and remember when looking for talent
it's ok to keep your head in the cloud
[Music]